mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
a sinisterly simple math puzzle for
elementary school kids stumps japanese
twitter adults according to soranews24
here's the puzzle
the two numbers 99 and 72 combine to be
27
then 45 and 27 combine to be 18
39 and 18 combine to be 21
36 and 21 combine to be a mystery number
28 and the mystery number combine to be
13
and 21 and 13 combine to be seven
what is the rule to combine numbers and
what is the value of the missing number
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
at first glance it seems that the rule
is to subtract the smaller number from
the larger number
for example
99 minus 72 is equal to 27.
we can check the next case
it is again true that 45 minus 27
is equal to 18.
if we continue
we can then see that 39 minus 18 is
equal to 21.
so we then would have 36 minus 21 would
be equal to 15.
if we then continue we would see that 28
minus 15 is equal to 13.
so finally we would have 21 minus 13 and
that should be equal to 8
but the very last number is equal to 7
and this is not a typo
therefore this cannot be the rule
we have to think of some other simple
rule to combine the numbers
so let's examine the very last three
numbers
how can we combine 21 and 13 to get
seven
after some experimentation you might
come across the possibility of summing
the digits in the two numbers
so we have two plus one
plus one plus three
and that in fact is equal to seven
so we have a new candidate for the rule
we can then check all the other cases
let's consider ninety-nine and
seventy-two well nine plus nine plus
seven plus two is equal to 27
so it works
for the next case
for 45 and 27 we have 4 plus 5 plus 2
plus 7 and that is equal to 18.
so it works in the next case
we can see this rule works for all of
the data that is provided in the puzzle
39 and 18
will have a sum of digits equal to 21
so then we would have 36 and 21
if we add up the digits in these two
numbers
we will get 3 plus 6 plus 2 plus 1 and
that's equal to 12.
thus that's the candidate
so we'll just go ahead and check we have
28 and 12 so the sum of those digits
will be equal to 13 and finally we
already checked that 21 and 13 the sum
of the digits will be equal to 7.
thus the rule is to add up the digits in
the two numbers and therefore the
mystery number is equal to 12 and that's
our answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube
see you next episode of mind your
decisions where we solve the world's
problems one video at a time
[Music]